Bonjour à tous, aujourd'hui dans ScienceClic,
le rayonnement de Hawking.
Notre univers est décrit par deux théories.
La relativité générale,qui décritla trame de l’univers
comme une surface lisse qui peut se courber, l’espace-temps.
Et la théorie quantique des champs,
qui décrit les particules comme des petits paquets d’énergie
à l’intérieur de champs quantiques.
Ces deux théories fonctionnentextrêmement bien
et modélisent dans leurs domaines
respectifs presque tout ce que l’on connaît.
Mais malheureusement
elles sontactuellement inconciliables.
Les calculs ne parviennent pas
à décrirel’origine microscopique de la gravité,
la façon dont les particules,
despaquets discontinus d’énergie,
peuvent courber une surface
continue comme l’espace-temps.
Cela dit, il reste possible
d’étudier lecomportement de particules quantiques
à l’intérieur d’un espace-temps
courbe, mais que l’on imagine figé,
en négligeant le fait
queles particules devraient influencer sa courbure.
C’est par un calcul astucieuxde ce type
qu’en 1974, StephenHawking
découvre un phénomène étonnant.
Hawking découvre que les trous noirs
produisent un rayonnement très léger,
qui à terme les fait s’évaporer.
Un phénomène qui mélangegravitéet physique quantique…
le rayonnement de Hawking.
Un trou noir est une région sphérique,
une “bulle” d’espace-temps, délimitée par un horizon
à l’intérieur duquel la gravité est siintense
que rien ne peut s’échapper.
Quand ils sont entourés dematière,les trous noirs rayonnent,
et on peut le détecter depuis la Terre.
Toutefois ce rayonnement n’est qu’indirect :
ilprovient de la matière à l’extérieurdu trou noir.
Le trou noir en lui-même n’est pas
vraiment un objet, mais plutôt une région,
et donc à priori, il ne rayonne pas.
Au niveau de l'horizon, l’espace est vide.
Mais ce serait oublier la physique quantique…
D’après la théorie quantique,
notre universcontient des champs,
qui remplissent tout l'espace, sont présentspartout,
même dans ce qu'on appelle le vide.
Les champs quantiques sont agités de fluctuations.
Ils contiennent des ondes
qu'onappelledes particules virtuelles :
certaines d’énergie positive
et d'autres d’énergie négative.
Le “vide”, en théorie quantique,
estsimplement l’état dans lequel les ondes
positives et négatives se compensent parfaitement.
Les fluctuations du champ quantique
sonttoujours présentes, mais rien ne s’y propage.
Une particule “réelle” estuneonde qui n’est pas compensée,
et donc se propage.
Revenons à la relativité.
Le mouvement naturel des corps
dansl’espace-temps est la chute libre.
Le tissu de l’univers est courbé,
et les objets ont tendance
à avancertout droit dans l'espace-temps,
ce qui les entraîne dans leur chute.
On peut représenter lacourbureautour d'un trou noir
par une grille qui se contracte
en accélérant au cours du temps.
Un objet au repos reste immobile,
ou en mouvementà vitesse constante,par rapport à cette grille.
A l'inverse, un objet qui voudrait
s'opposerà ce mouvement naturel de la grille
est forcé d'exercer une accélération,pour s’empêcher de tomber.
Localement, l'espace-temps semble plat,
lacourbure n’est visible qu’àgrande échelle, comme sur Terre.
Ainsi un observateur en chute
libren'observe rien de spécial,
et en particulier, il n’observe rien de spécial
au moment de franchir l'horizon du trou noir.
On a vu que l'espace autour du trou noir est vide,
et c'est le cas en particulierauniveau de l'horizon.
La théorie quantique des champsdécrit
le vide par un équilibre d’ondes positives et négatives.
Ces ondes sont définies
par rapportàla grille de l'espace-temps,
elles sont dans un état naturel, au repos.
Et un observateur en chute libre
ne mesure doncaucune particule,
il mesure bien... le vide.
Mais maintenant, imaginons un observateur qui,
lui, reste stationné juste au-dessus de l'horizon.
Pour éviter de tomber,
cet observateurest forcé d'accélérer constamment.
Mais parce qu'il accélère par rapport àla grille,
il perçoit les ondes positives et négatives de façon différente.
En accélérant par rapport à ces ondes,
illes reçoit avec des fréquences déformées.
En particulier, les ondes qui setrouvent sous l'horizon
ne serontjamais reçues par l'observateur
qui accélère vers l'extérieur.
La personne en chute libre
nedétecte pas l'horizon du trou noir.
Pour elle, localement, l’horizon
est un endroit comme les autres,
et les ondes positives et négatives
s’y compensent, l’espace est vide.
Mais la personne qui s’empêche
detomber, elle, détecte l'horizon,
car elle accélère, si bien qu’elle
empêche certaines ondes de l’atteindre.
Pour elle, les ondes positives et
négatives ne se compensent pas :
de son point de vue l'espace n'est
pas vide, il est rempli de particules.
Il est crucial de comprendre que les notions
de “vide” et de “particules” sont relatives.
Parce qu'ils se déplacent
différemment dans l'espace-temps,
les deux observateurs détectent les fluctuations
des champs quantiques de façon différente.
Tandis que l’un voit du vide,
l’autre voit des particules.
Au niveau de l'horizon du trou noir,
on ne peut pas dire de façon absolue
qu'il existe ou non des particules.
La notion est relative,
l’existence deces particulesdépend de l'observateur.
Jusqu’ici le raisonnement était purement local.
La notion de particules est relative
dèslors qu’on a un observateur qui accélère,
que l’on soit à côté d’un trou
noir ou dans un espace-temps plat.
Mais dans notre cas,
l'espace-tempsest courbé à grande échelle.
Et alors que la notion de particules
estpurement relative au niveau de l'horizon,
plus on s'éloigne du trou noir, plus l'immobilité,
qui constituait un mouvement
accéléré au niveau de l'horizon,
devient le mouvement naturel.
Ces particules qui existent
de façonrelative au niveau de l’horizon,
deviennent peu à peudes particules... “réelles”
en s'éloignant du trou noir
Ainsi, les trous noirs rayonnent.
C'est le “rayonnement de Hawking”
Les particules virtuelles près de l’horizon
deviennent des particulesréelles à grande distance.
La courbure de l'espace-temps fait la transition
entre une zone où il faut
accélérer pour rester immobile,
et une zone où l’immobilité est naturelle.
On comprend bien que ce rayonnement
neprovient pas de l'intérieur du trou noir.
Rien ne sort du trou noir.
Les particules que l'on détecte
à grande distance prennent leur origine
dans les fluctuations duvide
à l'extérieur de l'horizon.
Une façon intuitive d'interpréter le phénomène
est d'imaginer le vide comme une
soupe de particules virtuelles
qui apparaissent par paires,
une d'énergiepositive,
l'autre d'énergie négative,
et qui s'annihilent aussitôt.
D'ordinaire ces particules virtuelles
nepeuvent pas devenir de “vraies” particules,
elles restent indétectables,
Notamment parce qu’une “vraie” particule
doit forcément avoir une énergie positive.
Ces paires de particules virtuelles,
dont l’une est d’énergie négative,
doivent donc disparaître aussitôt.
Mais à l'intérieur d'un trou
noir la courbure estsi intense
que les notions detemps et d'espace s’inversent.
D’un point de vue externe,
ceci autorise les particules qui sont à l’intérieur du trou noir
à avoir une énergie négative.
Lorsque qu’une paire virtuelle
apparait à l'horizon du trou noir,
la particule négative adoncune chance d’exister :
si elle est capturée par le trou noir,
elle est désormais autoriséeàdevenir une particule réelle,
tandis que la particule positivepeuts'échapper du trou noir.
En absorbant ces particules négatives,
letrou noir perd peu à peu de l'énergie :
sa masse diminue, et petit à petit
le rayonnement de Hawking fait s'évaporer les trous noirs.
Le rayonnement de Hawking
est ce qu'onappelle un rayonnement thermique.
Le spectre de cerayonnementcorrespond parfaitement
au spectre émis par un objetdufait de sa température.
On peut ainsi attribuer
unetempérature aux trous noirs
correspondant à l'énergie de leur rayonnement.
Les gros trous noirs sont très froids,
car au niveau de l’horizon
lacourburese fait très peu ressentir,
et ils s'évaporent donc très lentement.
Et plus un trou noir est petit,
plusson rayonnement est énergétique,
correspondant à une température élevée.
Il s’agit là d’unepropriétéintéressante des trous noirs.
D'ordinaire, lorsqu'un corps
perd de l'énergieen rayonnant,
sa température diminue.
Mais un trou noir qui perd
de l'énergie enrayonnant rétrécit,
et sa température augmente.
En perdant de l'énergie,
lestrous noirs se réchauffent,
et l’évaporation s’accélère de plus en plus.
Cela dit, tous les trous noirs
que l'on connaît pèsent plusieurs
milliards de milliards de milliards de tonnes,
car ils se forment à partirdel'effondrement d'étoiles massives.
Leur rayonnement est extrêmement faible :
sa température ne dépasse pas
quelques milliardièmes de degrés au-dessus du zéro absolu,
et il n’est composé que
de particulessans masse comme les photons.
Le processus d'évaporation
estdonc complètement négligeable.
Il faudrait plusieurs milliers de milliards
de milliards de milliards de milliards de
milliards de milliards de fois l'âge
de l'univers pour les voir s'évaporer.
Qui plus est, l'univers est rempli
d'un rayonnement issu du Big Bang,
le fond diffus cosmologique.
Et en absorbant ce rayonnement,
enréalité les trous noirs grossissent.
Si l’énergie du fond diffus cosmologique
diminue à mesure que l’univers s’expand,
l’évaporation pourrait un jour prendre le dessus,
mais il faudrait pour cela attendre
plusieurs centaines de milliards d’années.
Toutefois, il pourrait potentiellement
exister de petits trous noirs primordiaux,
formés juste après le Big Bang,
dontl’évaporation pourrait être en cours.
S’ils existent,
on espère que leur rayonnement sera détectable un jour.
Pour le moment,
le rayonnement de Hawking reste un résultat théorique,
impossible à détecter à l’heure actuelle,
et qui se base sur une approximation :
négliger l’effet des particulessur
la géométrie de l’espace-temps.
Il nous faudra très certainement attendre
de disposer d’une véritable théorie de la gravitation quantique
pour comprendre ce phénomène avec exactitude…
en particulier les derniersinstantsde l’évaporation,
quand le rayonnement devient très intense.
Mais il s’agit tout de mêmed’uneprédiction très solide.
Beaucoup de calculs différents
aboutissent à ces mêmes conclusions.
En 1974, Hawking calculait
l’effondrementgravitationnel d’une étoile
et la façon dont le trou noir
enformation affecte les champs quantiques.
Une méthode plus abstraite consiste
à étudierle temps non plus commeun nombre réel,
mais comme un nombre imaginaire.
Il s’agit là d’une techniquede
physique statistique :
le temps imaginaire reboucle surlui-même,
et on retrouve la température
du trounoir avec la longueur de ces boucles.
Expérimentalement, on étudie déjà
lephénomène en utilisant des analogies.
En particulier,
on peut créerenlaboratoire un écoulement de fluides
quireproduit les conditions d’un trou noir,
avec une sorte d’horizon qui sépare un écoulement supersonique
d’un écoulement plus lent.
D’un côté, les ondes sonores peuvent s’échapper,
de l’autre,
le fluide étant plusrapide, elles sont capturées.
Ces analogies ne sont pas parfaites,
mais les équations qui les décrivent
sont proches de celles du vrai phénomène,
et plusieurs expériences
aboutissentà des résultats prometteurs.
Les calculs de Hawking etles recherches qui ont suivi
ont contribué à découvrir des passerelles
entre gravitation et physique quantique,
ouvrant les premières pistes vers
une unification des deux théories.
Pour la première fois, une formule,
celle qui donne la température d’un trou noir,
fait intervenir toutes les
constantes de la physique moderne,
un phénomène réunissant relativité,
gravitation, physique
quantique, et thermodynamique.
Le phénomène d’évaporationdes trous noirs
soulève des questions et engendre des paradoxes
sur notre compréhension de la physique moderne.
D’ordinaire en physique,
à partir d’un état final il est possible, en théorie,
de remonter à l’état initial d’un système.
Mais deux trous noirs parfaitement identiques
peuvent se former à partir
de deux étoiles différentes,
et une fois ces trous noirs évaporés,
il ne resterait plus aucune trace
du scénario qui s’est produit.
C’est le paradoxe de l'information.
L'information de ce qui aété capturé par un trou noir
semble se perdre à tout jamais une fois évaporé.
Peut-être que cette informationreste figée à l’horizon,
et est capturée, puis emportée
par le rayonnement de Hawking.
Ou peut-être que le trou noir
ne disparaît pas totalement,
et laisse un minuscule résidu derrière
lui qui contiendrait toutes les informations.
Pour le moment, nous ne savons pas encore.
Enfin, depuis quelques années,
le rayonnement de Hawking
a permis de mettre en lumière
un paradoxe encore plus fort,
lié au fait que les particules
virtuellesqui se séparent à l’horizon
devraientrester intriquées entre elles.
Ce paradoxe fait ressortir
leslimites de nos modèles actuels
dont certains fondements devront êtreabandonnés
dans l'espoir de découvrir, un jour, une “théorie du tout”.
L'une des approches pour résoudre ce
problème est d'abandonner le principe d'équivalence
selon lequel rien de spécial
ne se produit au niveau de l'horizon d’un trou noir.
Certains pensent qu'il existerait
un mécanisme qui brise violemmentl'intrication
entre la particule qui s'échappe
et celle qui tombe dans le trou noir,
une sorte de… mur de feu.